you know the data that I don't have my
game face on is the day I might lose I
wasn't as successful as I wanted to be
for a very long time but
the older I get the more I appreciate it
that process your life is yours to live
and when you let the voices of others
drown out your inner voice when you let
them start to talk and they start
dictating how you move he's an American
singer songwriter and actor his single
heart attack was nominated as best r b
song at the 2013 Grammy Awards he sold
over 14 million records worldwide he's
Trey Songz and here's my take on his top
10 rules for Success rule number six is
my personal favorite and I'd love to
know which one you guys like the best
and as always as you're watching if you
hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it in the comments
below put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well and when
you write it down it's much more likely
to stick with you as well enjoy
thank you
anybody that you know uh
puts their passion and devotion that
they love they time yes you know
dedication into uh you know you're gonna
get upset about that from time to time
you're gonna get and not only upset
you're gonna have every emotion about
what it is that you do when you really
love it yeah you're gonna you're gonna
Cry Sometimes about it you're gonna
you're gonna get angry sometimes you're
gonna be really happy about it but it's
gonna be times that you're very upset
whether it be uh in the way somebody
perceives your music whether it be your
mic getting cut off whether it be you
playing your music for an executive and
they saying I don't think that's it you
know what I mean it's it's so many
things as far as artists concerned so
when we speak about like working with
people like what's left it's so much
more left because I'm still finding
myself you know what I mean so as I make
music and continue to make music I I
just I just want to be true to me as a
person
that I don't have my game face on today
I might lose
you know that's a part of the focus
that's a part of knowing what you sign
up for uh
I know what I want from this and I know
what it has what it takes to get there
hard work ain't never scared me
I know what is I know what it's felt
like to not be the hottest
to not be as relevant
to not have
types top 10 Single after top 10 single
or number one single like the number one
single
so those moments are fresh in my mind
and I work hard to make sure that I stay
here my personal life actually takes a
back seat at times to this
and I understand that and my family
understands that and I work hard to get
all that it is that I want I always tell
people the biggest biggest benefit to my
career was probably in the beginning the
thing I hated the most like how long it
took me to get to where I feel was where
I was getting my just do yeah you know
my first album came of course the crib
is going crazy just gotta make it Gotta
Go Wonder Woman everything and our
nucleus on the East Coast we but I
wasn't as successful as I wanted to be
for a very long time but
the older I get the more I appreciate it
that process that learning curve the
ability to grow gradually so I had to
learn everything in front of everybody
like I didn't get catapulted immediately
into success
that gave me appreciation for the
journey to get to success that gave me
appreciation that made me work hard like
that's why I work as hard as I do now
today because I feel like if gotta make
it with a win number one Billboard Chart
type of success my first single ever I
don't I don't think I had this thing
just be honest I don't write down goals
and and go get them you know I know a
lot of people do that but I just kind of
try to outdo myself I'll do my last I'll
do and although this is a competition in
in every sport and I look at this
industry as a sport because it's it's
numbers and it's money and it's
achievements and his championships
Etc et cetera you know uh I'm only
really in competition with myself
you know although it is you know a fun
competition to look over and see what
your homie doing to see you know what I
mean for me is all about bettering me
bettering the music I make bettering my
Fan Experience better in my business
bettering myself as a man uh
and uh the truth is there's a lot I want
to accomplish in the music industry
there's a there's a lot I want to
accomplished accomplished as a
businessman and uh I haven't done a lot
of those things yet although I have done
a lot
I feel like I'm just getting my feet wet
in the ceiling is very high for me your
feelings get hurt in situations where
people let you down yeah or people you
know take your name to you know do
whatever for their success what I think
we as a people get to engulfed in is
what everybody else has to say about it
like your life is yours to live and when
you let the voices of others drown out
your inner voice when you let them start
to talk and they start dictating how you
move
you got to stand out you gotta you gotta
be strong within yourself I love to do
music so I always rap and I always and
you know the funny thing about is when I
was rapping and saying it was like it
was a something out of this world where
he's gonna sing and rap but he's a r b
singer like in the beauty I love about
music nowadays is that you have artists
that almost everybody do both right you
know what I mean so I think that's a
great part of the evolution of music is
uh artists being creative and believing
in themselves no matter what box that
people try to put them in because no
matter what you're trying to do with
your life other people gonna try to put
you in this box definitely so you got to
push through it no matter how great I am
how many records I sell no matter how
many hits I have I'm only a man I'm not
better than the next man
that was at a elevated level
around more in demand and you know less
of my time is my own
when I work hard when I work very hard
but I could work harder
is the way I look at it like and I'm
doing very good but I could do better
I'm very successful but I won't live in
that moment there was a point where I
was putting out a new song every week
you know it was
it was Trey Songz music Monday I put out
a new song every Monday for like two and
a half months
before my mixtape came out which was
anticipation which got 50 000 downloads
the first night
uh ready came up Ready's had six or
seven singles I think that has a lot to
do with it uh going on tour with Jay-Z
who's an international Superstar
definitely brings a lot of attention to
my name uh
I performed with Stevie Wonder on the BT
honors uh you know I kissed Toni Braxton
on stage you know like so it was a lot
of steps towards where I am now and I
think uh that it's just beginning even
still you know that's why I I'm this run
is so jam-packed my schedule that's why
I'm in a different country every day
because I need to make my presence fell
and and even when I come back next time
I work even harder to make my presence
felt because us I still I'm working here
this time like I'm a new actor my
manager told me we're gonna come out and
we're gonna act like it's 2005.
and what that means is we act like I
just got to make it you know so I don't
I don't feel as though I'm
a superstar here yet
I'm working my way there but I'm not in
it just for the money
you know the cars cars clothes I suppose
you know that that's and that's the
tricky thing about that song you know is
that when I say I suppose it's kind of
like thinking in hindsight is that
really was success is you know it's not
that's that's what success is perceived
to be and what we thought that it is
through TV through movies through videos
Etc but success is really what makes you
happy in your heart making music makes
me happy hey can I get the ladies to
make some noise
yeah
one two
[Music]
three
louder come on
baby
straight back to the crib
oh yeah
[Music]
very loud I just wanna see you friends
stay here
foreign
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Ruby Watson
asked me to also if you want to nominate
someone for the next top 10 video please
check the description for a link to a
video where you can vote for people and
put in your suggestions as well I'd love
to know what did you take from this
video what was the most important lesson
that you learned that blew your mind
that you're going to immediately apply
to your life or your business somehow
please leave it down in the comments
below I'm super curious to find out I
also want to give a quick shout out to
John Jenkins John thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and posting it on Twitter I really
appreciate the support man and I'm glad
you enjoyed the read so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon thank you
in life in general
you gotta believe in you you got to
believe in you and it's going to be
critics as you mentioned earlier critics
don't determine you you live your life
for you you do what you do for you
because the moment you start to live
your life for others You'll Lose
Yourself within that focus on what it is
that you want to have go get it I read
that you said something about you've
been getting a lot of scripts but you've
been putting your acting career kind of
on hold to get this album finished and
out this album in my musical career all
together I want to make sure that it's
at a certain level whereas though when I
when I take acting seriously and I want
to step into that Arena I could play
ball with the best of them you know I
don't want to try to juggle too many
things at one time because when I'm when
I'm focused on my music I give it my all
and if acting is something I want to
take seriously I want to be able to do
the same with that well with every album
I've gotten better you know as far as
sales are concerned as far as chart
placement I feel as far as Artistry is
farther as far as uh artist development
and growth you know so that's just part
of the evolution that I feel is is the
national progression of my story you
know I was on tour with Jay earlier this
year and the opportunity came about it
was a initial conversation turned into a
meeting turned into some paperwork
you know and uh
did the thing I love most about it is
how honest it is is uh and I think
that's what people love about the actual
campaign and the photographs and the way
that it's being delivered Rockaway as a
brand is changing and growing is and I'm
doing the same as an artist so I think
the the partnership works well for the
both of us